a devastating diagnosis for Celine Dion
sidelined from the stage for the
foreseeable future welcome to
Entertainment Tonight yeah this was
really painful news that Celine
delivered herself in an over five minute
video message to her beloved fans
I miss you so much
[Music]
I have no choice
but to concentrate on my health at this
moment
stiff person syndrome which affects
something like
one in a million people this is what's
been causing all of the spasms that I've
been having an emotional Celine revealed
the heartbreaking symptoms of her rare
and incurable neurological disease which
could prevent her from ever performing
in the same way again difficulties
when I walk
and not allowing me to use
my vocal cords
seeing the way I'm used to
people can die from complications from
the disease it's serious Dr terrazier
who isn't treating Celine but has the
disease herself tells ET the singer
faces a potentially debilitating future
many people require Walkers wheelchairs
some people are are bedridden they can
have spasms so severe that they break
bones dislocate joints result in
life-threatening breathing problems
forced to cancel eight shows and push
her already postponed European tour
dates a full year the 54 year old vowed
to return in 2024. I'm working hard
every day
to build back my strength and my ability
to perform again it's been a struggle
it's not easy
it's hard it's really hard I do know
people with SBS who do sing it's
definitely possible if she can tolerate
the physical therapy it may take
multiple attempts to to get back we have
to live one day at a time
in 2019 ET was behind the scenes on
opening night of the now postponed tour
and back in 97 we were on the music
video set for my heart will go on today
marks 25 years since its release
[Music]
if I'm tired of this and I don't feel
when I'm on stage it's time for me to
retire I would love to have a child or
children just over three years after
telling us that Celine gave birth to
Renee Charles the first of Three Sons
she credits them with giving her the
strength to go on I'm doing
everything that I can to recuperate and
I have hope
[Applause]
[Music]